well it doesn't come as a big surprise
because when I stand for for the
contingency of FIFA president I I want
you to reboot football because I thought
at the time that for many many years
some people have ruled the world of
football in a bad way and I think I
thought it was time to for change so the
news this morning with some people
arrested I think is is not very good for
football and you know what it's a is
probably the time for a new era in the
game of football we need to as I said we
need to rebuild the confidence on FIFA
people in in in the in the entire world
that's been asking too many questions
about are you deal with this how do you
deal with that I was it possible you
know this is not a kind of question you
need to ask yourself when it comes to a
decision on I always going together the
world in the next worker who is going to
rule the next the next four years as a
president of a huge association as FIFA
I mean you have to open the doors as I
said so this morning I saw that as yes
is huge news is it something massive
because we are talking about the game of
football the beautiful game and the
beautiful game shouldn't be in this kind
of news it should be only in in a good
way and especially from the people at
the top of all the structure and you
know mr. Blatter is at the top of the
structure is vice president as being
arrested we need to obviously to her to
wait for for for the allegations you go
through and it's it's an investigation
so the investigation has been through
many many men since we heard about the
world cup in qatar for 20-22 the garcia
report everything has been very very
special for me because i was looking at
it as a obviously possible so you asking
yourself about
are they going to give out a gift with
the world cup to qatar and you have
someone making a report on investigating
what happens and in all of a certain you
said well you saw me you can you can see
but some other way you can't this it
should be clearer than that whatever
happens it's certainly damaged or
further damage the reputation of FIFA
when you heard the news did you feel
sadness or anger in some of the
repetition of FIFA you know it has been
has been many years that you know we
were thinking well this is this is not
really clear what up what's happening in
Zurich the thing is you know people ask
me question when I stand for the
presidency why are you doing this why
are you doing that I said well because I
think we need someone outside the game
and when I say outside the game the
politician game to to just have a kick
at all the things has been dictated for
many many years and to see that as a new
as your new thing someone independent
someone doesn't have any interesting
term of politics in jail term of money
and it seems that amongst all these
there's so many interest other than the
football itself and the fans because we
forget most of the time that football
belongs to the fans and you know if you
look at the news this morning is really
a shame it's really a shame to see all
that because it shouldn't be the image
of the game anisette blaster is
concerned too he is due to basically be
another coronation on Friday he says
it's going to go ahead FIFA says it will
go ahead should it
will you mean as opposed a new president
election indeed sir yeah well I think
the timing the timing is pretty bad
obviously but you can see that you we
are in politics we are not in sports
some of the timings have been probably
you know this is this is a bad one
because because obviously there is an
election in a few days and we ask
ourselves our they are gonna work this
out but this don't forget is not the
people that were voting for for the new
presidents is the people amongst fever
so it's not if it was people from around
the world voting for the next president
I think it might have been different in
a way that people are there are 10
seconds this is something wrong there we
should just postpone the election and
and try to make it at a different time
maybe in a year time lets the the
investigator work work out the problem
and see who is actually making you know
difficulties making what was making
wrong in in the past I mean it was it
was pretty much what I decided to do
unfortunately you know when you start to
do something that is not never been
before people are probably asking
question that it shouldn't be and
someone having someone independence
coming to stand for something as big as
a president of FIFA might have been a
good thing can I ask you finally if I
may pleased a bit about what's happening
as well as 20 18 and 20 22 is concerned
we know at the moment that they will go
to Russia and also to quatre those world
cup so they are being investigated as
part of a Swiss investigation do you
think that it's fair that they should go
to Russia and to Qatar or do you think
it should be reopened is not a I don't
think the question is thinking about
what is fair what is unfair
the decisions are has been made they
devoted for vogue russia in 2018 and
qatar obviously in 2022 we spoke a lot
about it there's been many many articles
and you know conversation towards the
those two beads but that's it i mean now
we need to work out what is wrong with
FIFA can we make something different can
we change the whole thing can we look at
the future in a bright away towards the
game of football we all say that is a
beautiful game on and on the other hand
people who are ruling the world of
football are making wrong decisions all
the decision maker made behind closed
doors you don't know where the money is
coming from when the money is going I
think it should be more like as a proper
structure more reliable more reliable
and this is not so 20 18 8 20 22 let's
focus right now with what's going on
with FIFA and tomorrow I think when
we're going to see the real problem
maybe the Garcia report will be shown to
everyone we will see what's going on and
what happened in the inner visions month
and improbably mostly years and things
going to going to change okay things are
going to change and let me be very
positive with it I think is a really
good thing because in the way we spoke a
lot about FIFA in a bad way let's speak
about if you find a good way for for the
next two or three generations final
thought from you given that it does look
as though at least when I FIFA is is
unraveling who knows what might happen
with these investigations would you
consider again standing as president
as I said you know when I didn't get I
didn't get my nomination the five
nomination at the end of January I said
clearly that it wasn't the end of
something it was a start of something
and as I said this morning I was in
surprise i think is a good good thing to
to reboot the game of football and it's
probably the right time right now we
need to think things out and we will
just need to do the right thing so yeah
probably and if the people are this time
more behind someone there are no
interest at all in doing this I mean
it's just about the passion of the game
let's make sure that the fans will be
pleased all around the world let's make
sure that you know FIFA is going to pay
tax in every single work up they
organize around the world let's bring
more transparency democracy and equality
does the three key words FIFA in the
next few years they need to concentrate
on okay it's great to talk to you thank
you very much and do for joining us on
sky do sir Sir thank you thank you thank
you thank you